الاموات الهائمون او ما يعرف بزومبي مشهد
مستزاخ في افلام الرعب للتشويق الذي تدره
في قلوب محبيها لكن المشهد نفسه يجتاح
الشوارع الامريكيه في الواقع نسيم لوس
انجلوس ويزرع الرعب في حناياها حيث اظهرت
فيديوهات شبان يتميلون فيهم الاستجابه
للمحيط بل تحركا دون هدف
[موسيقى]
تقارير اعلاميه اكد انتشار مخدر جديد اسمه
ترانك وهو مزيج بين ماده
حيث هو دواء بيطري يشبه كوكايين ويعطى
للحيوانات الضخمه كالاحصنه بغرض تهدئتها
اما الفتنه فهو من اخطر انواع المخدرات
مخدر زومبي هو يعمل على تخفيض معدل ضربات
القلب ومن يتناوله يجعل منه شخصا خطرا على
نفسه وحتى على الاخرين وقد يؤدي الى الموت
تاثيرات هذه الماده غير المعتمده لاستخدام
البشري تشمل ايضا النعاس والنسيان وبطء
التنفس وحتى انخفاض ضغط الدم هذا المزيج
القاتل يسبب للمدمنين عليه تقرحات جلديه
متعفنه بالقرب من موضع الحقن ما قد يؤدي
في النهايه الى بتر الاطراف اذا لم تعالج
وفق ما نقلته صحيفه ديلي ميل عن اطباء
اداره مكافحه المخدرات كانت حذرت من زياده
الوفيات بشكل مخيف بسبب الجرعات الزائده
من
لاسيما انها تستخدم كبديل رخيص لماده
الفيتنال
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات